why for 36 years I put up with it now I
must stop Grinch movies from coming but
how so yeah I'm gonna talk about the
Grinch but before I do I'm gonna make a
real quick note it's got absolutely
nothing to do with the rest of this
video but I feel like I want to do a
quick additional acknowledgement
yesterday we lost Stanley I'm not gonna
dedicate a video to that because I don't
feel like I can do the man justice and I
think the post I put in the community
page for this channel says about as much
as I am capable of saying and I will
miss him and he he brought a lot of joy
through a lot of what he did both in
writing and and just as a person so
moving on to something that did not
bring me nearly as much joy as Stanley
did the minions people's the Grinch no
I'm not gonna call it dr. Seuss is the
Green Team and though that's the
official title cuz there's this and dr.
Six's the Grinch is just like I refused
to call Jim Carrey's How the Grinch
Stole Christmas dr. Seuss's How the
Grinch Stole Christmas cuz it's not now
before I get into this and get too much
into complaining because yes that is
largely what I'm gonna be doing allow me
to start with a major acknowledgement I
saw this with my daughter she's actually
the reason I saw this left of my own
devices I would not have gone to see
this movie but so here's the first big
thing if you have kids young kids my
daughter 7 they will probably like this
in fact they'll probably love it I
actually asked her this is her favorite
version of the Grinch
she's seen all three she likes this best
then the Chuck Jones short version and
then the live-action laxed so yeah if
you have young kids the people who this
movie is actually made for the
probably love this however if you're
like me and you grew up on I'm sorry a
much better version of this or God if
you grew up on the book yeah it's not as
bad as the live-action version for a
number of reasons first of all it
doesn't have the weird sort of creepy
uncanny valley thing with the design of
the who's going on that the live-action
version had so that's point one and it
doesn't make white all of the same
mistakes there was particularly one
major mistake that the live-action one
made that this one does not and that was
a live-action version basically making
everybody kind of awful like the only
decent human being was cindy-lou in
their live-action version like the who's
were all terrible people and so like
what is the basic concept of how the
Grinch Stole Christmas the who's get the
value of Christmas the Grinch doesn't
the live-action version decided no the
who's don't get it either
which was weird and dumb now this
doesn't do that however it does still
make most of the other mistakes that a
live-action version made I'm including
you and that largely comes down to how
they chose to Pat it out because this is
the fundamental problem with basically
every single feature length dr. Seuss
annotation there is dr. Seuss's books
are exactly as long as they need to be
they are incredibly economical he'll
they'll be like maybe one or two more
pages or more flourishing paragraphs
than there needs to be but strictly
speaking they do what they need to do
and once the job's done
they they're over and what the things
that you have to add to that to paddle
out to get feature-length they just they
never help because ultimately dr. Seuss
stories aren't really about the
narrative when you think of dr. Seuss
you think about the turns of phrase and
the images and the flow of the of the
poetry you don't necessarily think about
the substance of the story that's not
saying that
was no substance in Doctor Who there
absolutely was but it was thematic it
was about messages it wasn't about this
happened then this happened then this
happened then this happened which is
part of why they go so badly with
padding them out because there's really
there's there's no fat on these stories
and adding fat in doesn't it doesn't
help so you just end up with these
things with these really weird and
bizarre additions like like one of the
things this does which the live-action
version did to which is to give the
Grinch backstory and a reason for not
liking Christmas now while again I will
grant it is neither as drawn out nor as
stupid as what was in the live-action
version it's still infuriating to me
that it's there especially considering
and this is probably my single biggest
gripe about the movie the narration done
by Pharrell for our Williams I think so
he I'm used to just call him by that
name who puts out music so first of all
all due respect to the guy he's not a
great narrator his voice does not work
for this very well at all so but even
setting that aside about 90% of the
things he say are not from the story
that's not inherently a problem but we
need to like make a law where if you're
not dr. Seuss don't try to write dr.
Seuss and I'm not even talking about
that dapped and write his poetry like if
you're doing a flat-out spoof that's one
thing don't try and actually recreate
what he did in his voice cuz you can't
nobody can and the fact that's almost
all the narration because I know this
story front to back I know the truck
Jones animated version front to back and
I know the the original book front to
back none of these these things that
they say are and it just drilled into my
brain every second
and but what so what's so additionally
infuriating about that is one of the few
lines that they kept from the original
work was the Grinch hated Christmas the
whole Christmas season now don't ask why
no one quite knows the reason the reason
the fat line is in the book is because
it doesn't matter why The Grinch hates
Christmas it has no bearing on anything
and you even kept that line yet you
still gave him backstory and the reason
that he hates Christmas oh for God's
sake now as far as the Grinch himself
goes honestly he's too nice not that
he's like a good guy but he's like he's
just kind of cranky he's just he's just
the grumpy neighbor who doesn't like
going shopping during the holidays cuz
he doesn't like the creek the Carol's
being blasted at him that's that's who
this Grinch is he's not it's not seeping
into it there's no sense that his heart
is actually two sizes too small
he just doesn't he just he's just not
into the forced joy of it I think maybe
part of the problem is they really
there's an awful lot of Max in this
movie which is far the reason my
daughter likes it so much because she
loves dogs to death so by bringing in
more max that means they upped the
Grinch's relationship with max and they
gave him a very loving relationship with
max and while that's kind of cute in it
in and of itself it's very undermining
of the Grinch as a character because
he's not a mean one this mr. Grinch and
it's like it was the weirdest thing that
early on he has to go grocery shopping
and like if you've seen the trailers
you've seen part of this he goes
shopping in Whoville like that if I knew
wouldn't feels like that's fundamentally
wrong the idea that he at any point like
the whole thing is like he stocked up
fur for the winter so he wouldn't have
to go down didn't shop during the
holiday season but like he's gone
through the food faster than any spacer
so he needs to go shopping there like
set aside the holiday context of that
like just the idea that the Grinch goes
shopping in Whoville
because that feels wrong that feels
really really wrong to me I and look I
I'm gonna readily grant I am possibly
overly attached to the to the Chuck
Jones animation cuz you know I grew up
on it that's my childhood that's my
nostalgia but I just think it's better
I'm basically every level because what
does this have going for well Benedict
Cumberbatch's Grinch is not a
particularly great Grinch honestly even
though I think overall this movie is
better than live-action I think Jim
Carrey's Grinch was better than Benedict
Cumberbatch's Grinch I do think this is
the worst Grinch so there's that that
doesn't help
but you know that so since it doesn't
have a great Grinch going for it I mean
what does it have it has some cute
animals okay illuminations decent at
that and it's got some cartoon slapstick
illuminations also decent at that are
you better than Chuck Jones at that no
no you're not almost nobody is so I just
yeah I I didn't want to see it I wish I
hadn't seen it but again like if you're
not me if you're not my age with my
attached to the original my attachment
to the ones I grew up on maybe you won't
hate this as much I still think it's
kind of pointless like there's it's just
it just doesn't it seems to get the
overall story and point better than the
live-action one did it doesn't seem to
get the Greek as a character very well
though and you know there's there's lots
of isolated little things that are funny
it's not without decent moments it's not
without a few laughs there's a thing
with these carolers basically likes
talking after the Grinch's he's going
through the town streets that's honestly
kind of funny there's this there's a
extended thing with a reindeer that has
its moments that aren't bad max is cute
but overall it's just yeah it probably
comes in just behind horton hears a who
as being
one of the least offensive of these
adaptations I mean it's not the Lorax
that was legitimately offensive but you
know it's these aren't good and they're
never gonna be good the best they're
gonna be is fine because dr. Seuss's
stories don't work Pat it out to an hour
and a half
they just don't they're not built for
that they don't survive the process you
have to put them through in order to get
that and personally for me this movie's
just more proof of that so illuminations
the Grinch what did you think of it
whatever you thoughts are drops anything
down in the comments let's talk about it
hold what's the stuff you can do down
there cuz there's buttons oh there's
links including one to the patreon if
you feel like supporting me that way but
if you don't don't sweat it cuz there's
other things to check out as well you
don't even have to look at those either
if you don't want to because at the end
of the day you are the council and just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]